when college students go home for the
summer it can be a complicated reunion
one of our viewers told us on Facebook
suddenly the car is never around and the
food bill goes through the roof and I
would add here suddenly it seems that
the dirty dishes on the kitchen table
can't get to the dishwasher even though
it's only four feet away I added that
part CBS News contributor and
psychologist Lisa d'amour recently wrote
in the New York Times
adding college students back into family
life is rarely as simple as rebooting
their high school days Lisa good morning
complicated is the word is yeah what
actually is happening so what's
happening is that everyone is entering a
new chapter in the parent-child
relationship and everyone has to figure
out what that looks like because the
kids the kid who comes home thinks he's
independent I'm referring to a specific
yes but they expect someone to do their
laundry still well it's interesting
because sometimes I feel like I'm on
vacation yeah right and often they're
very tired and they come home tired and
I had college didn't say to me I'm on
vacation but nobody else is on vacation
and that is a strange thing to have to
adapt to what I think is interesting is
they're they're used to coming and going
as they please yes and they when they
come to your house as a parent you're
very concerned when you coming back who
are you going to be with are we allowed
to ask those questions because they take
it as an as an insult I think that when
are you coming home is an absolutely
fair question and yet I think we have to
be prepared that for the kid who's been
really independent it can feel like a
loaded question yes so it may be worth
taking but it's a fair question
it's a right question but I think it may
be worth taking steps to reframe it a
little bit and I look I'm not trying to
control you this is about sort of the
courtesies of us living with one another
should we expect you for dinner or
should we set a place for you do you
think you're coming home give us a sense
but to maybe make that extra gesture to
say we're in a new chapter but we still
have questions to ask so one of the
things that kids can bring home from
college are bad habits habits they
didn't have when they left yeah and I'm
thinking in particular vaping these days
if you set a rule as a parent that you
might have done whatever you did at
college but no vaping under my roof at a
good policy it can be a good policy
quitting nicotine is not easy right so I
think that parents shouldn't expect that
is just as simple as saying you've got
to stop this
you know on a dime they may need to help
the college student take steps to
irritability I suppose or put up there
with some irritability and the same
thing can happen you know I've talked to
parents where they've got younger
siblings at home and the parents might
say we get it that you drink in college
but you're not cracking a beer in front
of your tenth grade brother you know so
making those those adjustments as a
family also Lisa you're so excited to
have them home so you have lots of plans
we're gonna have dinner together we're
gonna go here we're gonna go there and
they're like no they have their own
place they actually have their own lives
they do what's what's the dialogue
between the two well it was a child
thinking what is a parent thinking so
you know parent is exactly like I can't
wait to see you I can't way we're gonna
go visit all our old haunts yeah when I
talked to the college students about
what was top of mind for them coming
home
they said I'm excited to see my old
friends I miss my college friends they
are often interested in the romantic
landscape they left behind I had one
young man say to me I don't know where
things stand with my high school
girlfriend and I said is the outcome of
this gonna shape your summer he was like
oh yes the other thing they expressed to
me was this intense nostalgia for
physical spaces their favorite
subchannel their hike yeah and the most
touching thing I heard one one young man
said to me I have been in touch with my
parents I feel connected to them yes I
can't go to this particular Bluff I like
to climb until I am at home and able to
do that parents loosen up is your bottom
line I think assume best intentions oh
yeah all right Lisa d'amour always good
to have earlier